[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
ryan good day sir good
day to you i feel off man
i feel off uh halloween's around the
corner i'm doing these awesome movie
nights
um zooming of course with my zoom
friends my
horror friends so we've been watching a
lot of horror movies we got a new poster
the thing poster
sounded like russell i'm a nerd i know
and the evil dead
my buddy my good buddy bruce campbell
hey rosie pants
stay groovy or try ash bruce campbell
evil dead
you never expect to do anything with
your life and uh then you uh start
all these heroes that you you're working
with them now and you're
it's not that you don't feel like you
don't belong you just kind of go hey man
this is cool i admire this movie i
admire your work uh
bruce will be back on the podcast too so
and that's a glorious one
i really enjoyed that one yeah uh i want
to say uh thank you to everybody out
there i got a sympathy card
it was from a lot a lot of people i
don't have to name everybody but i got a
nice card from
some patrons of mine and i really really
appreciate it
i mean kristin and alison and leah and
um
yeah so they wrote me a sympathy card
for my sister and that was really kind
of them
and uh i appreciate you and also got a
mug from a bunch of
folks here look at this look at this
nice mug here nice mug from my patrons
they're all on there and um
we love you rosie and i love you too so
uh thanks for joining patreon thanks for
supporting the podcast uh
just a reminder if you enjoy this one
and you're listening
hopefully you'll subscribe and uh tell
your friends and all that stuff
uh announce the uh the top winners from
if i didn't do it from the stage yet we
do uh live
shows where i play music and we're
making an album and
my friend dancing so the right now we
help me with the band title write into
the show hello at insidey podcast or
tweet me or instagram me or whatever but
or patronize me but it's uh we're still
thinking of a name i think it's rose and
bomb and dancing i'd love to come up
with something wittier but uh
i don't know top winners from august
release a haul
from team rogue flask and leah stubbs
thank you
um and top owners from september team
rogue flask but that was a big raj
raj gets a shout out and kristen keough
and leo stubbs
uh man so i've been watching the vow on
hbo max
have anybody seen i know whitney
cummings talks about it a lot she's
obsessed with it and a lot of people are
obsessed with it but
it's about this organization nexium that
became sort of this cult
and there was uh sex slaves and
branding women and all this crazy [ __ ]
terrific stuff horrific stuff and
you didn't know a lot about it you knew
of it but you didn't watch the
documentary now it's close to me in a
way because
um allison mack who's on smallville who
played chloe who
i thought was you know amazing on the
show and a sweet girl and
you know we didn't really hang out but
uh
it uh she she was part of this
organization so
you know back then and you'll hear me
talk to sarah just in a second but
it was um when i found out about all
this stuff i was sort of ignorant about
it i was like i don't i don't believe it
it's like somebody tells you you know uh
you know your brother did this
yeah it's my brother i don't think
you're i know my brother
do i um it's it's just kind of the whole
thing's a mess and it's
a sad story but it's you know there's a
lot of bravery
to this i think uh the people who
somehow were able to get out
of this and just say hell with it and
be ridiculed and you know it's it's like
it's
you'll listen to the interview i think
you're going to really learn a lot from
it and um
you know in no way was i ever
you know am i defending allison or
um i just knew her at a certain point in
my life
and um uh you know
i know that she's done a lot of bad
things you know
yeah this is this is what i'm i'm
gathering
and uh and it's hard for me to sort of
uh
understand that and i think i'm getting
to understand it more that people do
change i think people
are you know i you know we talk about
brainwashing and things like that but
you know it's
i don't know you know when i first
watched the episode as i say to
uh sarah you'll hear it but i felt like
wait a minute you know this is kind of
this is kind of a cool thing and then
also
then you realize wait a minute this is
completely [ __ ] but of course you got
to
understand that the people going into it
didn't think it was [ __ ] they thought
it was going to help them and it was
interesting and this guy was a genius
and
uh his iq was off the charts and he had
this insight that nobody else had
so i i like to give the benefit of the
doubt to people people could always sit
there and go oh my god you're so weak
how could you do something like that oh
my god those people that you hey i just
kind of get annoyed by that because
you know sorry that uh we're not as
strong as you or people aren't as strong
as you or maybe they are
yeah i mean there's some really bright
people that got involved in this
and um i don't think if you know if they
knew for a second that it was
so bad what the guy did and what he was
capable of doing and
he was a master manipulator so this is
just a really interesting story and you
know not only did sarah come on the
podcast but
her husband nippy uh nippy was there and
he talked to me for a minute
and um get some really interesting stuff
and uh i i maybe one day allison will
will talk to me about this i don't know
i just
i think that sometimes you know you
think you know people it's like you know
when you were in high school
ryan oh yeah do you remember people that
you were like
bad or good you're like that guy's an
[ __ ] well yeah
you know 30 years later you can't go i
hate that guy
i bet he's not that guy yeah there's a
good chance
or maybe he is but on the um
the converse of that is maybe you met
somebody there that was really sweet and
you liked them and now you're like you
have nothing in common they are not that
person i don't know
is that the case yeah i can think of a
couple people you want to name them
yeah like for instance if if you found
out all of a sudden
a year later you didn't hear from me and
then you found out i went to prison for
being a mass murderer
just be like you have nowhere to hide
bodies yeah they're all filled with
posters here the whole house so i really
don't have any room for
any bodies but i mean i think
something tells me you gotta know the
people you're hanging around with you
got it
but sometimes you just don't sometimes
you just
don't know the darkest deepest secrets i
wonder if jeffrey dahmer
and by the way i'm not this isn't not an
analogy but maybe it is it's a bad
analogy
but the people who hung out with jeffrey
dahmer they might say it was a little
weird he was a little
but did i think he was like dissecting
like animals and
you know people and cutting off their
heads and keeping them in the
no his father had no clue yeah i mean
maybe there were signs but you
you don't look at them because you're
like uh there's no way this is jeff
this is old jeff with two f's he
wouldn't do that
what i'm trying to say is i never really
knew allison
i thought she was sweet she was easy to
work with
she was talented and then you hear this
and you're like
wow but then i think i didn't really
hang out with her a lot i didn't really
know her
um i always knew she needed attention
like every other actor like myself uh
you know there were some things but
never in a million years so
it tells me a lot of things it tells me
that uh people can be
manipulated depends you know your
vulnerability how vulnerable are you how
how much do you want somebody to save
you
take you in protect you give you
confidence make you love yourself
and at what cost i don't know this is uh
let's get inside of sarah edmondson
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
okay okay i also grab some tissue
because i
i'm feeling there might be tears that
just could happen well
listen you i just
here's what i would like to say okay
this interview
is look when i speak to people it's
always
whether i like it or not in layman's
terms because that's how i speak
okay and i don't want to talk about
people thinking they know
everything about this isn't this is sort
of to educate people about
like this story and your story and so
it's not about we start throwing names
out and this and that but i think it's
like you know people are listening going
i don't know who sarah edmondson is
i think it's really important that you
know your story and and who you are and
where you come from so
the way i want to present this is just
really talk about you for a minute
before we get into
you ever watch like horror movies and
you're like because this is kind of a
horror movie in a way
right it is yeah it's definitely a
horror movie yeah because you watch one
in the f you know if you
you never liked the characters in the
beginning you're just like you just you
watch the
you watch everybody getting killed i
don't care about anybody so
you have a really i mean you know it's
just an interesting story and you're
such a likable person
that it's like before we get into some
of the stuff that went on it's like i
want to i
want to talk about you for a second and
like i mean because you're from
vancouver
mm-hmm i'm from vancouver i'm here right
now where do we meet do we meet i feel
like we've met
i i don't know you know i don't think we
i feel like our paths may have crossed
when you were here doing smallville
right that's that's what i was thinking
in like the
early 2000s but i i remember when you
did the movie in germany with jamie
ah that's 20 years ago very many years
ago 90
years ago so i mean i knew who you were
but you
probably didn't know who i was but you
know that's probably i must have seen a
picture of something but we were
probably following each other for years
i guess on twitter and didn't even know
it i was like oh yeah yeah
i was like wait a minute and then i kind
of put it together you know what i mean
yeah but i feel like
i mean are so many interwoven
times or either could have met and and
um
yeah well we'll see what transpires yes
we will
i mean so and also by the way it is a
horror movie but i can't laugh
like i have to laugh oh so don't
don't don't worry about like
i'm not that sensitive like you can ask
me anything or whatever like
yeah no no and i think anybody who knows
me knows that i will ask anything but
like
it doesn't come out of like you know an
interrogation it's more like
i'm just curious and like i feel like
you know i'm a fly on the wall and
you know and and by the way i was going
to i was working with
allison allison mack who was on
smallville with me
and uh she was
i think doing this while i still on the
show obviously
so i you know we can get into that
but before we get into that because she
ended up being one of the
i don't know would you say the heads
what would you call it the
she was definitely one of the key
leaders of
the nexium and then and the dark stuff
that was the underbelly that we all
discovered which made headlines right
which is
believe me shocking to me too coming
from someone who worked with her and
seen this kind
you know you know innocent girl
turn into a woman and then like whoa
wait what we'll get into that
so beforehand so you were raised in
vancouver and you were
like you had a pretty good relationship
with your family they were always
supportive what was that about
yeah i mean my i've had a really
wonderful
easy kind of vanilla upbringing my
parents
um are both very politically socially
active they really taught me
like in the 80s my dad would take me on
peace rallies and we'd you know my dad's
a folk singer
as well as a counselor but he's also a
folk singer and you know we would be
marching and singing for
you know the things that we believed in
and that was always a big part of my
upbringing like
make a difference and and and stand up
for what's right
i didn't realize how much that would be
in like interwoven into my like value
system until later
um but yeah my parents split up when i
was two and a half which i think
um kind of since we're doing the
you know personal stuff i'll tell you
that i think that
at a very core level if you're gonna
cycle analyze myself
i never i was always looking for safety
and fitting in and
i didn't really fit in very much during
like elementary school and high school
was bullied a little bit it's kind of a
nerd
um and was like looking for my
my tribe my people i wouldn't have
called it tribe because that's sort of a
word of now right right but you're click
in a way some
a group of people that you could relate
to and i think we all do that right i
remember
i didn't fit in anywhere in high school
i was the smallest kid in high school i
i get it
and i just wanted to belong to something
and then you go to college and you start
to meet a couple of people that you're
like oh oh they kind of get me or
and you figure it out and you start most
people just go on through life and then
they find their people
right so exactly but it's that quest
yeah it's a quest and i think i
originally found it in my in high school
with like
it was a bit of a theater nerd so i was
in like the theater program and that's
where i started acting
and then i went to um a jewish summer
camp
where i really felt like accepted and
um i kind of joked that maybe that was
my first cult because
it was a little bit a little bit there's
a little bit of dogma there that was uh
you know kind of thrust upon us and
ultimately i think i
rejected a lot of that but i love the
sense of community and that
and camaraderie and acceptance and that
was you know such a nerd i looked back
at those pictures when i was 12 and i
had like
big red glasses and i like put i was
kind of a hippie too like the braids in
my hair and like
doc martens and like big yin yang
sweatshirt
and like like it's it was
it was a it was a look for sure but it
was the 90s so
but then he's trying to do my best yeah
but then you started like so you started
acting and this and that nice you know
you got some roles it wasn't like you
were a unemployed actor who just never
worked you
actually had some success you were on
you did fringe you did
uh the show that uh one of my other cast
members was in uh called
edgemont you did edgemont you did yes i
mean you did a lot of things you were
working so ultimately
i mean did you feel i mean because you
weren't married before right
before you met no no i was in a
different relationship
at the time and with my relationship and
my career i just felt like
i don't think like a lot of people do in
their mid-20s i was like 25 26 27
it's like what's is this like is this my
purpose like your commercials and
you know that's what i'm doing now at 48
i'm i'm still i think we're it's a
concept
no i'm not doing a beer commercial it's
not that i wouldn't i'm just saying
i think i'm oh we're all out there
trying to find purpose
and you hate to sound so cliche but it's
like that's what we as humans we
are trying to find our purpose like what
are we here for what can i
do to feel more fulfilled feel good
about myself
i think that's all part of humanity and
so yeah yeah
i think i think those two main things
looking for belonging looking for my
tribe and looking for like okay what
what am i here to do and i really felt
like yeah i was a working actor
but i was like there's more and i always
like since i was little
i think i had a vision of like at one
point in my life i'm gonna have a
certain
whether it's celebrity or platform to
have a voice and have an impact and
at that point i thought it was it's
really ironic for young women because i
had such a hard time in high school
that i was like if i could just help
women with their self-esteem
well girls i guess before they became
women or i didn't even i didn't know
what exactly but i was like i'm gonna
have a voice
like and acting was not it so
when i got introduced to esp which
everyone knows is nexium
it was like oh my goodness maybe this is
my my tribe
maybe these are my people right so how
did so how did this happen how old
you're 25 26 and you just
is it on a bulletin board does someone
because i think well
it's mark mark kind of brought you in
right mark yeah how did you become
friends with mark who directed a movie a
documentary
which was a big documentary called what
the bleep do we know correct yes
what the belief it's called not what the
bleep do we know just what the belief
is i actually just call it bleep just
bleed
so how did you meet him and then how did
this all happen
so and i still have to get you a copy of
the book because it goes into much more
detail about this
guard is the book scarred yeah book is
card and
it goes into a lot more detail than the
vowel especially about this part of my
life which was
i think you know not very long but it
was a real quest i'd watch with the
bleep i'd read things like the artist's
way
um celestine prophecy it was in the
beginning of my like spiritual journey
i've done that and we watched with the
bleeper bleep and we loved it and then
my boyfriend at the time was a filmmaker
got us into a film festival where he was
like you know as a director and i said
i'm coming with you because it was
called the spiritual cinema circle
festival at sea
this doesn't exist anymore it's run by
an amazing man named steven simon who
uh directed what dreams may come with
robin williams just this
really great guy anyway it's a long
story but this long and short of it is
the very first night they sat me down
with the director of what the bleep like
science seating
and uh we had a conversation that uh
changed my
trajectory of my life and he told me
about nexium and ultimately
i never googled it i never you know
checked into it i just like well i like
him i like what the bleep and he's
telling me about this group of people
that are
working together to shift humanity like
this is it i was looking for my purpose
and it landed in my lap this must be
my purpose right you just felt like it
was just because he seems like a
magnetic person like there's this
magnetism
to mark he seems like just a genuine guy
who's trying to do the right thing you
know obviously
he gets as we know as we soon will learn
listeners who haven't that
and you could watch the vowel on hbo max
and you could also read scarred
um sarah's book but he is definitely
he's got that charisma and you're like
what a talent he's a filmmaker he makes
something that really makes me think
i don't need to read you know sometimes
when people that are just very
influential or that you like or you just
innately trust right away
tell you something you kind of just go i
don't need to do the research i trust
this person
right we do that yeah and that's what
you did
absolutely and it just happened like i
went on that cruise
specifically asking for like a sign for
what is my purpose like what's next in
my life i'm gonna be around all these
spiritual people making movies and like
i've
you know mark and i talked at that
cruise like we're gonna make
movies we're gonna make media that shift
consciousness like what the bleep
i don't want to do beer commercials
anymore i don't do vampire tv tv shows
no offense to my friends we do mount
fire tv
shows there's a lot of them and some of
them are great but i want to shift
consciousness
you know and that's really idealistic i
am aware of that like i kind of have to
i judge myself a little bit for that but
the irony is not lost on me that here we
are making the vow cut to
i'll go back to that in a moment but
like the vow is really
teaching people how groups like this
exist and how they work and how they get
people and how they rope them in and i
feel like i mean obviously it's not the
path i wanted to go on but
we're educating people you know we're
really teaching people how this
how this happens yeah well you know that
means a lot to me
yeah absolutely absolutely in fact i
wanted to say this because i wanted to
be honest about it when i'm watching the
vow when i watched the first episode and
believe it or not even though i
i knew alice said i didn't really follow
up on all this stuff
i knew about i was like wow i kind of
believe it but i don't believe it how
did that happen there's got to be some
reasons i don't know
i just never we're not really that
educated until someone makes a document
documentary that sort of uh really dives
into it and then you're willing to take
the time to go
holy [ __ ] this is what happened because
let me just say this i watched the first
episode of the
and i was by myself and i'm not going to
lie i said to myself i go
i do this no i go i would this i
i need some more self-esteem i need more
confidence i would like to
have more of a purpose and then by the
end of episode two i was like
[ __ ] off what the [ __ ]
this is you know and so now my
point is that we're all vulnerable to
some extent
and there i was like if i i'm sure if i
would have met somebody go oh wow these
are great people this is cool this is
the guy who directed that and
he must be these are and they're helping
people out and they're
i could understand why people get into
it and then
of course like look if obviously if you
take out the uh the keith renery who is
as he calls himself the vanguard if you
take him out of the equation
of all the sex stuff and the [ __ ]
which we'll get to
the slavery and all that sex slavery but
if you just
got rid of that stuff i mean there's a
lot of good
to it in a way it's just people
become i think they're the messiah
complex they have this bigger than
at this power i don't know what we can
get into that but when you your first
day
on when you went to a nexium meeting
it's called it was the next cm meeting
is that what it was
it was a it was a five day uh five days
like a seminar workshop but before
bookmarked that for one year that's
going to tell you
how i mean just how great that is that
you had that reaction because
up until now so many people are like
i've never fell for that and
these people are dumb and blah blah blah
and to have to
to know that people and i'm telling you
people are instagram
messaging me i totally would have joined
in fact some people have said listen
um where can i get some of these tools
like this sounds great does it exist
anywhere else
can you help me like i want those things
my friends have asked that they've been
like you know
if you take all the crazy [ __ ] out from
the beginning before we get there
there's some the intention seems like
the intent seems like
hey these people just want to get better
and and just be
better human beings which is a great
idea it just kind of falls apart a great
idea in fact
nippy my husband i know you know him
from the show i heard him cough a few
minutes ago hi nippy he's just over
there
hey nippy good to see you i hear you
hey man he just has a little bit of a
little bit of fomo oh that
yeah well he could join at any time
we'll bring him in down the road if he
wants to
whatever sometimes when we're doing this
he's like
there's certain things that he likes to
riff on that he's really good at riffing
on so i might bring him in as a
special guest honestly nippy you feel
free to jump in whenever you want this
is a
just open platform you know honestly
it's just we're just tr i'm trying to
and the listeners is just trying to get
to understand how someone could get
into this which i just talked about by
watching the first episode so you did
this five-day seminar
and you were you were blown away no not
at first
the the first three days i was very
skeptical
um it was really cheesy like the whole
presentation was very like early 90s
and i just like nancy salsman she's
getting up there and she's kind of just
like you're going
on a video that they played i'm like i'm
paying over two thousand dollars to
watch the president of the company speak
on a video
in this cheesy holiday inn in burnaby
by the way burnaby is like yeah burnaby
burnaby that's where we yeah suburb
you know that i mean burnaby's great but
like
not this part of burnaby
it's called burnaby it was very i was
just judgy and
um you know i was very much like my
parents are therapists
what are you gonna what are you gonna do
for me here and kind of like
ushering in like this is more from my
boyfriend than for me kind of
kind of thing like fix him um
and actually on day one i was so turned
off by the
calling keith vanguard and and the
sashes i called
mark vicente and actually googled for
the first time on day one
and there was stuff about them being a
cult but not
nearly the stuff you can find online now
there wasn't any particular
like what was really bad about it wasn't
clear it was just like their culty i'm
like okay but what
what's what's what's the bad thing that
they're doing wasn't there but i said to
mark like this is what did you get me
into he's like do you believe everything
you read on the internet
and i was like no i was like well you
know have your own experience wait till
day three and see how you
you know how you do um that was one
thing that happened but the other thing
that's really
important for me to educate people on is
that they said to me like right from the
beginning like okay we're all here to
grow and learn and
be the kind of people we want to be
everyone agree that that might be
uncomfortable at times
you know and everyone's like nodding yes
yes of course when you're
when you hit those things those areas of
discomfort you're going to have the urge
to bolt to leave
and we're just asking you like if you're
really here to you know get your money's
worth
stick through those those moments and
know that there is something for you to
look at if you
if you hit one of those things for
example sashes we wear these sashes
around our neck
that was super cheesy didn't like it um
and then that would mean you have an
issue with like measurement or like
there's a ranking system so you have an
issue with authority
which may or may not be true you know um
or calling keith vanguard why do you
have a problem with that like which if
you were
in a court system would you call your
honor
bob because you don't want to use the
term you know
right right right like every single
thing that was weird
had a an answer and if you had a problem
with it it pointed to a thing within
yourself so i kind of learned to go like
okay i'm uncomfortable which means i've
got something
now this is like i trusted mark and i
trusted the system
a lot of not a lot of people but maybe
one in 30 would come take our training
and they'd be like
no especially if they'd grown up and say
another high control group like
jehovah's witness
or you know uh an extremely religious
um background or whatever they'd be like
i've been there done that
you said one in 30 would say no but
you're saying that the percentage of
people that would come
in and go to these seminars once they
were there most of them were in
most of them were in but i'd say almost
every training we did there'd maybe be
one person on day one that had such an
extreme reaction
to either the sashes or the vanguard or
something that they were like i'm out
and then they were out and we and keith
actually
said that all of those things were what
he called the guardian at the gates
so somebody had such a reaction to that
and meant we didn't want them in there
because they were suppressive
it's oppressive ah yes so like
you learn to like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna voice anything but being
uncomfortable with this because it's
just gonna expose that like
maybe i'm suppressive right right
so that base assumption that if i'm
uncomfortable
i'm gonna override that is one of the
most dangerous things that they did and
i think keith knew that to
systematically dismantle
intuition so your gut he was getting rid
of your gut so to speak
yeah and saying because here's the thing
your gut there is truth in the fact that
i could have a feeling that might not be
right like i could meet you and maybe
like
your eyebrows reminded me of somebody
that hurt me like 10 years ago and it
triggers me and that's not based on any
kind of reality
right so that happens
but there's also truth to say if my
body's saying f
out i should listen to that right so
he's screwed with that ability to
to have a moral compass and you think
that was his agenda all along
yes to sort of get rid of your gut
response and make
you go past that so you stay with it
yes to not trust yourself your own
intuition
yes that's to make somebody else the
author wow that's that's
for lack of a better word that's that's
[ __ ] right but you know maybe at that
time it's like
you're seeking all these things this
these con this confidence
what was it that in that five-day
seminar was there a moment where you're
like
i feel like i should do this this is
going to help yeah what was that moment
there was a couple and mark was right by
day three i was sold
um i had a number of big shifts and
i do think as you know even though i
believe keith is a sociopath and a
narcissist and all those things
is brilliant and he repackaged a whole
bunch of
therapeutic models into one five-day
so some cognitive behavioral therapy
neuro-linguistic programming
um basic buddhist beliefs about
happiness and where happiness comes from
which is i'm sure you've heard by now
it's an inside job
you know nothing from the outside world
money happy no no yeah
no they're great yeah so he
cobbled these things together and you
know if you you've done
anyone's done therapy you know you
usually go like once a week if that
right that's an hour a week imagine
doing 15 hours
12 to 15 hours five days in a row
you're just like working through stuff
working through stuff working through
stuff and
having these huge awarenesses about like
you know my relationship to money my
relationship
to acting my my relationship to like
what my values are and
and this exercise where like you write
down all your values and what's most
important to you so you can make it i
had a really hard time making decisions
before esp
i'd be like should i do this i should do
that should i do this job or that chat
should i wear this or this like i just
i was a nightmare to those around me so
now i had this like decision making
tool which really helped me and esp was
it's
it's the name before nexium right yeah
that's so that's executive success
programs
right that's what you went to an
executive success program which
ultimately is nexium which became next
scene yeah nexium wasn't even a word
that was on my radar until much later
was the parent company and esp executive
success program was like a subset of
that right that's what the training was
that i did yeah i just want to let
people know that
and yeah not esp
exactly exactly um but i'd say my big
you know i had a couple big ahas but my
my biggest was about my
my relationship to my self-esteem and
why i didn't feel good with within
myself as a person
um and then on day four and five you
have what's called an em which i know
the vow explains really well
which is basically you bring the
facilitator something that you
react to like something that's a
constant trigger
um i don't give me give me an example of
something you
react to always like like negatively
yeah
like probably uh you know when people
aren't appreciative just i think um
people aren't appreciative it just i
don't expect like when you give someone
someone to say
you i i don't ever respect anything in
return yeah just
you know a thank you or something just
just an appreciation
i think it's appreciation but it's
something i think it's personal it's
like you know
i always feel like i'm a giver so all i
ask is for just love and support and
just don't be an
[ __ ] to me and you know and so when
anybody does i'm like gosh man i feel
like i give you everything and you [ __ ]
on me
i don't know go ahead what's your
trigger well i think
ultimately knowing what i know now
i would leave that one alone because i
think that's a that's an indication of
what's important to you and it's
an emotion that's that's healthy um
but what we worked on initially was like
maybe unhealthy
not reality based emotions like the
first thing i worked on in my five day i
know this is really petty but
i'd walk into my apartment and my
boyfriend at the time
left dishes in the sink like not like
unrinsed and not in the dishwasher
like super petty and i would my blood
would boil and i would just be like ah
it was hard kind of square right yeah i
i dropped like three f-bombs yeah
of course such a pony mouth i'm really
trying yeah you can f-bomb i mean look
you don't want to f-bomb constantly i
have a friend joe who's always throwing
f-bombs i'm like dude joe
i get it f-bombs are all right but like
every time it's like people it
starts but you're not f bombing i'm
trying to reel it back because i owe my
son a dollar for every f-bomb and i've
been doing this for three weeks i own
like almost eighty dollars
well it's really what that's your
freaking mouth sarah wash your mouth
so i have this reaction dishes in the
sink and i bring this to my facilitator
and what so what an em
is is that it it takes something you
stimulus response like dishes anger
and people can relate to like you know
confrontation anger
um criticism fear like whatever whatever
is a consistent thing in your life that
you
have a negative reaction to is something
that as a facilitator we'd
look at the the memory this is through a
process of questions similar to
cognitive behavioral therapy if you've
ever done anything like that
which looks at the memory underneath the
um
the initial reaction so like for me as a
kid i
had a memory of my parents splitting up
at a young age
and um for me dishes and the facilitator
would sort of elicit this
dishes caused the breakup like i
remember them fighting and then they
broke up
so the dishes is linked to this like
terrible time in my life and i'm two and
a half and my parents split up which is
very traumatic
so as an adult now i'm like gearing up
for this scary thing to happen but i'm
not conscious of it
so what an em did was it looked at the
early childhood belief system
underneath whatever was causing the
reaction and kind of reframed it
in a way like the facilitator would say
something like what if dishes didn't
cause your parents to split up
so they'd insert new information that
would shift the whole meaning so that
me as an adult can go and see the dishes
and i don't have a freakout does that
make sense
yep it does so that's what i had i had
one of those
and it was profound for me i know it
sounds really good
were you really emotional when you get
these breakthroughs do you feel like
you're
like you were constantly emotional like
they were it was this you know it was
cathartic to get all these things out
and understand why you're doing
different behaviors yeah in the five day
i say probably like i cried
multiple times laughed cried often times
it'd be like wow i can't believe i went
through my whole life without
understanding
that um about myself or about people
um and uh oh
baby's awake you got it we were losing
nippy to put the baby back to sleep
[Music]
way to go nip good thing he's here
awesome husband um
i lost my train of thought well you were
just saying that you
cried you laughed within this five-day
period just going through all these
things about
your life and um you know the the dishes
weren't
you know you got you had to take away
the dishes in terms of like relating it
to like this isn't why your parents
broke up and this is
sort of yes so i get that so you were in
and
what was the next step ultimately they
were like asking you to do what
the next step well the five as soon as
i've done the five day
and the facilitator would start weaving
this in through the through the
curriculum she's like well
we don't get into xyz until the 11 day
so the five day was really the beginning
of a 16 day training and i was just
doing the beginning
and she even said something like imagine
that you have cancer
and they you know going in for surgery
the five day is really just prepping
your body for the surgery
we haven't extracted the cancer yet so
now i'm like
i gotta extract the cancer i have to
keep going
and by the way it's how much more money
to get to
cancer about 5 000 for the next 11 days
so you went 2 000 and another 5 000 look
at 7
dollars to get to but it apparently
some [ __ ] goes down we were like wow
that's the best seven thousand dollars
you know it's funny because i went to a
place a while back just to get my head
straight
and it was a lot of money and my buddy
goes what's the most important ass that
you have i go i don't know in my house
maybe i don't know my
this is like no dude you so no matter
how much money you put into yourself
that's the most important part
so you were probably thinking this is
they were probably throwing that at you
weren't they
this is your health this is you this is
the most important thing forget
everything else that will come
yeah i mean they said that to me and
then i said it to others
for years after that it's like
everything else is an effect
of who how you are with you you know and
i
i was i listened to the the interview
you did with jennifer love which i
thought was great and made me cry
by the way but she was saying something
about the life that she tries to
live with you know joy and certain way
with her children i was like she could
have been doing an ad for esp right
there because that's really
what it exists like almost word for word
how i want it to be
but there's things that get in the way
like there's the ideal version of
yourself and then there's how you are
right and esp helps you get there this
is what this is how it's pitched like
anything how much would you spend to
have this
it's a no-brainer if you believe that
it's a no-brainer
right what we know now it's embarrassing
but at the time it was like
of course i'm gonna spend that money i
didn't have it just put on my credit
card
yes so you didn't have the money did you
tell your parents about this
i did and they were very very skeptical
and
um you know my my mom took the stance of
you know she actually came with me to
take originally to take the trainings
just to be closer to me and see what i
was so passionate about
but she she caught on to who keith was
like right away
how soon right away i mean nobody really
knows what we found out
like at the end but she could tell that
he was a megalomaniac and
that you know she was just a concern
that you know any any group that says
it's
the way and we we really did think it
was the way and like
the only way to be joyful and have the
life that you want
you know wanted we really did i was so
self-righteous about that
but your mom said you gotta get out of
this you can't do this
she didn't do that because she's a
therapist she knew that groups like this
if she was really forceful with me that
i would push her away
and she was she right yeah she was right
yeah and the
and next team did a lot to undermine my
relationship with her
and to um well she's a therapist and
so in nexium therapy was
subpar compared to what we did right
therapy was
you know you could talk and talk and
talk it's not going to get to the root
of the issue
like an em would right so i really had a
huge disrespect for therapists and any
modality that wasn't this
which is again part of like my
deprogramming is to
reconcile that like just how
yeah self-righteous and um and
ignorant i was well how did you yeah how
did you how did you pay for this i know
you said credit cards but
it keeps going and so is there a point
where you stop paying and you become
part of nexium men
at that point yeah so there was a point
where uh
after my first five day they said if you
refer three people
you get your money back so i did that i
referred three people like immediately
because i'm always very
passionate about whatever i'm doing and
then you're an actress you could sell
them
and you know what i've always been good
at sales like i've been good at sales
since i was
i mean i had business cards at age 12.
you know if there was a fundraiser at my
school to like raise money for a new tv
or whatever i always sold the most
granola bars or whatever it was because
that's just what i don't know
right so you did you got three people
immediately
got three people immediately i got my
money back and then i used that for more
training so i
basically i got into um there's a bunch
of career paths with the nexium and
sales is one of them and i use that
to take more trainings so i just kept
taking more and more trainings and more
and more trainings and more training and
you felt like you were starting to just
become more confident
finding out who you were and do you
think now
retrospectively you were losing yourself
at the same time where you just
weren't aware of it or do you think you
really had like true growth
and felt like i'm feeling better than
i've ever felt
like where did it stop you know what i
mean yeah i think it's a great question
no one's asked me that um i feel like it
was a bit of both
it was i was having true growth because
like i said keith was really good at
stealing awesome
methods from other places right you know
like
and i can tell you now that i'm out of
it looking at other books that exist
where he stole from and how he did that
but anyway i was having a real growth
but i was losing myself
in the mission of the company to the
point where i was like
you know there was a time when i was
starting to get more acting and i did a
film that got into
tiff and that was really incredible this
is like four years in and then there's a
certain point where i started to feel
badly
for choosing acting over esp like it
there i had to make a choice like what's
the most important thing and i was like
what is this film gonna do versus like
i'm you know saving humanity
you know it's like yeah so that's where
he lost that's because you felt like you
were really truly helping people you're
like this is my purpose this is more
important than acting
now were they also at this point giving
you a salary or like you getting
paid after it took me four years to get
to the point where i could get a salary
i had to get to the level of what's
called proctor so it's an orange sash
where you're an official coach
and and a lot of people don't even make
it there and that's one of the things
that
um you know eventually woke me up cut
you know cut too many years later i
realized that
um it was well keith actually told me
this it's a chapter in my book it's
called the illusion of hope
he was really painting this illusion for
people
trying to get up the stripe path and
holding out this vision
but really it was i mean the whole thing
was a sham
um so a lot of people never earned an
income and a lot of people
invested a lot of money trying to like
get to this level and i think because
i'm kind of um
i mean i'm a bit competitive but i'm a
go-getter and i'm a doer like i don't
sit still
very easily like i it's hard for me to
meditate or just be with myself i like
to just do do do do
and they i was like a poster child for
them because i went from like
basement suite actress you know aspiring
actress to like a superstar within the
company
i say company loosely but we thought it
was a company back then
right well but they were honestly paying
you like
good money at a point yeah in the middle
in the middle chunk
like i'd say three or four years i was
making pretty good money really good
money actually
like what's good money without i mean is
it your is it your book
it's in my book but i mean it's it's so
weird because people take it out of
context and they forget that i have to
pay taxes
you know and like it's a substantial
amount of money
that you like you work towards a year
after year working your ass off and they
saw the drive
and like any other company if you see
someone working that hard you give them
bonuses and bonuses and so you start
making look uh
you know i'm assuming it's yeah you know
is anywhere between like
i remember when i was in the in like
2011-12 era like in my middle chunk it
declined after this because
messed up things that happened i'll tell
you about later but for a couple years
there's anywhere between like
five i remember a couple months i had
got like a check for 20 000.
and that was huge it was more than ever
made in acting
and you were you were broke before this
and here you are making this making good
money and then
i mean granted a huge amount of that
went back like
we did the jeunesse training which is
this women about the women's thing that
that alison got involved in
that training itself was fifteen
thousand dollars like the trainings
themselves
got more expensive and you you had to
commit more and uh mark and i at this
point had opened a center in vancouver
and so we were paying like my rent for
that was eight grand a month so it was
like yes i was making good money but i
feel felt like i still was like on the
hamster wheel
right right yeah cause i remember you
saying or maybe it was bonnie
who was also one of the women who was an
actress who got involved in this
that she like it was never the right
time and she's busting her ass and
working hard to get to that next level
and they're like yeah you're just not
ready you're just not
was that you both of us had that i think
she articulated it really well and i
showed like
the lifestyle we were leading it wasn't
like i was just sitting back and
and cashing in checks like we were
morning
tonight working with people coaching
people practicing rem's going to
trainings
i worked my ass off um and
it was always like you know to get to
the next level yeah you just haven't
worked this um you just gotta
and i believed it i was like oh i wanna
be better
you know and there were many times i
wanted to quit along the way but
at a certain point there's the sun can
cause fallacy like i had invested so
much i had a five-year lease at our
center downtown vancouver i'm like
pointing at it
um and who is your boss like i mean it's
obviously keith
is the vanguard but then you have nancy
who's below him who's like you
who do you report to i mean i reported a
lot to mark but he was he was more of my
business partner and friend
um i didn't have a very close
relationship to keith
in fact like the way that people
idolized him or adored him
i had that more with nancy and with
lauren
um they were the people that i really
like i mean at different points i
probably checked in with different
people depending on
my rank in the company which obviously
changed over 12 years
but um right lauren lauren lauren
salsman nancy salzman so they're sorry
yeah she's the daughter of
nancy salzburg right and she was the
nancy was the one that's on the tv and
the in the first time you went there and
she's selling this you're like what the
hell is this and then ultimately became
very close with her
nancy's the princess of the company and
like the main teacher and like i really
looked up to her i thought she was
really skilled
she really helped she felt like she
really cared about people and
wanted to help people and i want to be
like i want to be like her and lauren i
really
aspire to both of them and why is that
uh because they could sit down with
somebody in like 10 minutes
it felt like mind ninja them and
whatever they were working on or
struggling with
so quickly and i wanted i call it like
an em ninja i want i wanted to be able
to help people at that level
um and they really they were
they were skilled they were skilled at
the tech i say tech is that's what we
called the
the methodology right i think they were
just good therapists
and you met nippy anthony your husband
there how long into it before you met
him uh
i joined 2005. i met him in 2006
a year later and what was it at a
function uh it was at the center in
albany
um mark picked me up from the airport
and said there's this
this guy in from la it's really cute his
name's nippy i was like
well and um i showed up at the center
and he
he was like doing some some [ __ ] he'd
like his pants pulled up really high
he'd like camp camel toeing his balls
yeah we've all done that
you pull your pants up and it's just
like what the hell is this guy doing
yeah that's so
yeah i don't think i mentioned that in
the valley he's gonna probably kill me
that i decided yeah but
i like him he sounds like a normal guy
that's what we did back in college but
but he's not nippy's a real um he's a
bit of an enigma he's like
you know this quarterback ivy league
alpha guy
but also like super um
sensitive underneath and like really
wants to be
you know the best version of himself and
has big ideal like i think both of us
were just so idealistic about
having an impact on the world and that's
probably the way we connected the most
we were friends for a couple like three
or four years before
no three years before we ever hooked up
i mean
it's pretty baffling when someone
because it's such a great idea the
thought of like i just want to help
people was that was it truly altruistic
was it truly
i just want to help people get better
and make the world a better place there
wasn't any ulterior motives at this
point you really this is the mission
yeah 100 and and you know there's haters
out there and people like oh well she
was making good money
the money was a bonus for me money was
like oh my god i'm getting paid to do
this
i did it for four years without pay like
it wasn't it wasn't
i've always been a helper a giver
a caretaker like i'm the you know the
kind of person that like will have the
lozenges in my purse and be like oh
michael you got a cough let me give you
this i got some vitamin c you want some
throat spray like
people who know me will attest to that
right to the point where it's kind of
annoying they're like sarah
we don't need whatever you've got in
your purse which is like
huge always by the way so you talk about
other levels
like there was another level that
allison was going through what was that
called
oh jeunesse jeunesse what's jeunesse so
janessa was like so if you look at an
axiom and then here's esp
janas was another company underneath it
right
and it was a women's group and it
started around 2006.
so that's what she would have been in we
had a the very first jeunesse
it's like a woman's um
similar to esp but looking at issues
between
men and women and like the way it was
pitched to us is
you know what is the essence of a woman
and what is that and how can we bring it
out more in the world
and keith would say things like the
dalai lama said it's going to be women
who changed the world so it was all
about like
you know women women's empowerment which
is so ironic because he was
that was obviously not his intention but
he was he was tapping into
a certain trend that was happening in
the world where women were starting to
speak up and
you know um you know whatever you want
to call the new new wave of
feminism or whatever and he
it's like he he knew about that
marketing you know right and could
and could give that to us in such a way
that we thought we were going to get it
with this new jeunesse program and
that's where
that's where allison actually did
jeunesse first right
now sarah and claire bronfman
sarah they're the seagrams uh all right
sorry
sorry sarah but they're the seagram's
heirs right
worth billions of dollars and then we
find out that this
money is how nexium all this stuff they
were they were
writing the checks for all this correct
yeah they were i mean they were in
before i was in so right
how they got involved i don't i don't
really know but what i do know is that
keep was looking for
wealth and to have you know heiresses
like that
bankrolling the company and we've since
found out that he lost a lot of their
money on the commodities market
um and then also claire went off went
after people
using her money as a as a weapon in the
in the
legal system i don't know if you saw it
two days ago what happened i think i
sent you the link right yeah
that she went to prison for seven years
for what she
what she did for keith she was like are
you familiar with the term flying monkey
yes a little bit but go ahead oh yeah so
like narcissists often don't do a lot of
their dirty work
they have other people do it for them
like the wicked witch of the west
exactly see when i say layman's terms
this is how i equate i'm like oh the
flying monkey is like wicked
that's why they can't find monkeys there
you go that's what i thought i just
wanted
one of kate's top flying monkeys
and so she would get anything he wanted
ultimately
yeah whatever he needed he had her
convinced that
um protecting him legally and going
after the people that were trying to
attack him
was that was like her job and she felt
very um
you know like purposeful doing that
which is you know i don't know if you
know this but there's still loyalists
that exist
there's like they said there's like 60
or something that are still
i would say probably closer to 30 or 40
but there's like five who are on the
front lines that are doing press
right now and um cbs just did a piece
about them and they're like dancing in
front of keith's prison
trying to shine light on the injustice
of the legal system and the prison
system
which i'm sure is a true thing
but that's not why they're doing it
they're trying to you know um
you know shine light on keith's
victimhood which by the way
is my one of my main challenges right
now the whole
dogma of esp is that there's no victims
like something happens in your life you
can look to find out your role in it
which is very
um it can be good right like if you if
you have a pro
if there's a problem in your life and
you blame everybody else
it's a good thing to go like how did i
participate in this how did i cause this
right no victims but suddenly now keith
is a victim
he's a victim to the fbi he's a victim
to the system the justice system and now
he's in jail and he's
i'm like i had to like i'm so frustrated
i want to shake these people i want to
shake them awake but i can't
well ultimately you get into this thing
for growth
and to help the world and to help other
women and to help
people and you meet these people these
characters along the way nippy who
becomes your husband
who you love and trust mark who kind of
brought you in
um you know and my bonus husband
your bonus husband right and then of
course barbara boucher
which we don't have to really get into
now but she kind of became sort of a
mentor to you
right and uh people you look up to
everything's going you're
starting to make money you're doing
something that you think is good for
humanity
and what was the first thing
that you felt
remember all of a sudden after years of
not feeling your gut
your gut comes back into play ironically
and you're feeling something what was
that feeling and what was it
exactly that you're like there's
something [ __ ] here there was a couple
things happening at the same time
um this is way before dos even
people started women who were close to
keith start to get sick from cancer
and die and i thought there was
something in the water
first um i know there was a lot of
industry in that area of albany
um but it also just in two like i
hated going to albany i hated going to
trainings there i like the people like
the training themselves but i hated the
whole i felt like
that was something in my intuition that
i managed to to keep away and also away
from
from keith right to never be too close
to him
um so that was my first time i got
really sad like don't then they were
pushing me
hard to move to albany like i would i
was never gonna get to the next level if
i didn't move to albany
i had to get over my materialism and
that's where the headquarters were
yes in albany in fact alice and max
house was in albany
yes she moved to albany i don't know
when um a couple years after maybe four
or five years after she joined i don't
know but she was she i mean she moved
there
nikki moved there a bunch of people gave
up and excuse me their acting careers to
move there
um the other thing this is going to
sound really silly but one of the first
things that
just pissed me off and i couldn't get
over was um
at one of the vanguard weeks which is
the these birthday celebrations they had
was kind of like summer camp for adults
which was
really fun for many years and then it
was really not fun
but um as a as a high rank just me this
is my last year there
uh we promoted people and i was a at
this point i was a green sash
i was one of 12 greens in the whole
company and that was kind of a big deal
and we would present like okay this
person's ready to get to procter and
this person's ready and this person's
ready
and lauren said that um her sister
michelle was ready to go to proctor
now michelle had been a coach the whole
12 years that i'd been there
like she was a coach when i joined and
then i passed her and went way past her
so like she'd been the same level the
whole time
and all she needed to do to get to her
orange was to enroll one person
that's all she needed and i had enrolled
at this point like 100 personally
and all the people that they were 100
people
you've recruited at least a hundred at
least yeah and then the people that
they'd enrolled
like in what's called my organization
was like the imagination right right
people who wrote people there was like
approximately 2 000 people
that started from you that came from my
right my little family i call them my
my family right and here's this other
person who just needs one
she's one she's in one so i'm like get
it together i even tried to help her
multiple times because like enrollment
was not
every stripe along the way by the way
required three things your emotional
growth like to get through your issues
taking certain classes and being able to
teach certain classes and then three was
enrollment
so if you couldn't enroll people you
would never go
up and enrollment was super easy for me
where i got stuck was the emotional
things because they would say well
you're still
whatever control control was my thing
still controlling i'm still controlling
i think that's innate i don't think
that's something that you lose right
away i think that's just a human thing
that some people a little controlling
you you work i could be controlling i
could be like
what do you do you just kind of like all
right i'm aware of that oh look the
the picture is a little crooked do i
really need to fix it right now i'm ocd
let's not have control you don't have to
do that you take control of not doing
that that's control
yes you've chosen not to do that really
why are my engineers going what the [ __ ]
are you talking about son
are you a control freak michael no i
mean i don't think i'm a control freak
but i i
i certainly i i'm setting my ways a
little bit yeah
and i think that's fine so ultimately
what i came to like post next year was
like
i'm fine the way i am i don't need to
like take all these courses and spend a
lot of money and
needle around in there and just like
accept who i am right i like things
but wait but so what else so that was
part of the gut thing that you were
feeling okay that's not right you don't
like going to albany you don't i didn't
finish that story anyway lauren says to
me
michelle finally has her enrollment to
get to procter and i said great we can
enroll her proctor as a
you know promoter departure and she said
well she doesn't have the application
people had to sign an application to go
to a program
getting the app and she didn't have the
app yet but we're gonna promote her
anyway like what
the app was the the like the solid thing
that needed i know this sounds so stupid
but to answer your question i was like
why are we promoting her if she doesn't
have the app after 12 years
she doesn't have the app then she can't
you can't promote somebody on a verbal
yeah yeah i'm taking a five day you need
the paper
to prove it that was always the thing
that was needed for
my entire time there and lauren said
well keith said we can promote her and i
said
he said we can promote her what the [ __ ]
like you can't you can't promote
somebody unless they have the app and
i got like ver like i got upset i said
well
and they said to me sarah keith decides
who gets promoted there's a lot of
people here
getting promoted um who aren't ready
like we promoted you to green and you
weren't totally ready
and i was like what i had my enrollments
like but you hadn't worked through x y
and z but we thought it'd be good for
the whole company to see
sarah being promoted to green like so i
didn't earn my green sash
anyway it was this whole thing where i
realized that the stripe system that i
invested so much into that i thought
meant something meant nothing
and that people were getting promoted
because keith wanted them to
but there was a there was an alter
ulterior motive there i mean obviously
do you think it had something to do with
he wanted to sleep with her perhaps
no i think they wanted people to they
the morale was low in the company and
like i think it would have been good and
also i think
it would have been good for lauren if
michelle had grown it's
it's a complicated thing to explain the
straight path and the promotions and all
that stuff
it was the first time that i realized
that it was like not based in anything
and but we that wasn't even so bad it
was more how everyone pounced on me
all the greens who were my friends and
basically were saying i was suppressive
i was being anti-tribute auntie keith
and i got in trouble
for questioning keith i'd never
questioned keith before
and i was like i can't question this it
doesn't make sense to me someone
explained it to me other than keith said
and that was the first like this is not
right
it can be a little frustrating
especially if you're in a hurry or
you're running late
to find yourself at a railway crossing
waiting for a train
and if the signals are going and the
train's not there yet
you may feel a bit tempted to try and
sneak across the tracks
well don't ever you see to the naked eye
trains appear to be further away and
moving slower than they are and they
can't stop
quickly even if the engineer hits the
emergency brakes right away
it can take a train over a mile to stop
a mile
by that time it's too late and the
result is a potentially deadly crash
point is you can't know how quickly the
train will arrive the train
can't stop quickly even if it sees you
it ends in disaster
if the signals are on the train is on
its way and you
just need to remember one thing stop
trains can't and what is trouble
when you say you're in trouble what does
that mean because like if i'm talking
about something and i go
yeah well my friend tom's a real [ __ ]
oh you're in trouble with tom
it was more like the meeting ended and
lauren sent
this guy alex who was the head of this
center in mexico who was my coach
she sent him to come talk to me and to
see if i knew what i had done
and that i had a breach now with keith
and a breach with lauren
and i would have to fill out what's
called a breach form
to explain what i had done and how that
uh was bad for me was bad for the
company it was bad for keith and what i
was gonna do to fix it
and you're thinking [ __ ] you gotta be
thinking [ __ ] you oh my god i was
i was this close to saying [ __ ] you but
that would have been another breach
for him that's like me working at
mcdonald's my freshman year in high
school it's just like
that's it you're getting written up you
didn't you didn't we had to mop with an
arc
you know the arch of like the mcdonald's
m so and then dip
started to get off course here but i was
like i'm not doing that's a stupid
you're getting written up
what do you mean i'm popping maybe i'm
not mopping in the arch with the m but
i've written up for that [ __ ] and
stealing big macs but go ahead no that's
that's exactly getting in trouble was
basically somebody coming and telling
you that you've done something bad and
you had to fix it and you just felt i
just felt like [ __ ] about myself but i
also
i don't know like i've learned since
that when you're in a call you have your
your actual personality and then you
have your cult personality
and your cult personality kind of takes
over while you're in the call
and this this part of sarah was very
obedient and
very much a good girl and did all the
things but inside had been growing
increasingly increasingly more like go
[ __ ] yourselves
and just taking the parts of esp that i
liked and doing that
in vancouver i never was gonna move to
albany i was never gonna do like i just
that didn't resonate with me but i but i
said that i was
like yes i'm coming to albany i'm gonna
look into my visa and like you know
right i was like playing the game you
know this part of me is getting stronger
do you think that if you look back now
people who aren't part of this
organization do you think you kind of
didn't give them as much attention or
didn't care as much and it was more of
like
this is my group these are my people
[ __ ] everyone else and they're beneath
me
did you feel that i do and i and i and i
i'm still
cleaning up the effects of that people
who were like
i wasn't part of the community anymore
and you ignored me and i'm like
even your parents were you neglecting
your parents would you stay
with them i see pretty close to my
parents but i think like you know esp
was always the priority like i missed
major family events i missed one of my
really
closest friends of the world her her
wedding was in la when i was
i had to do a training and i missed it
and i ugh like
i regret that so much in fact when i got
out and she had a baby
shower in l.a like flew down i'm like
i'm not missing anything now i'm here
i'm
gonna make this up to you and and she's
been great and thank god i never tried
to recruit her because
our relationship is clean and pure and
that's just what i have to focus on but
there's a lot of people who i'm sure
were like
you know hurt by that because i was i
was so insular and it wasn't like
it was very much like outside out of
mind you know i was
working so hard it was i had my group
and like if you're not part of this
group
you're not with me you're not part of my
team i'm here and i'm doing this as go
go go and that's
been a huge part of my reconciliation
leaving is like you know
who do i need to make amends with on
that outside and that's probably what
they were doing there they would
probably try to bring everybody in and
this is your life let's just they have
something to do from the time they wake
up to the time they go to sleep and
within a couple years they'll have
nobody else they'll need us it's almost
like you then
need each other to keep going was there
that kind of need like
i'm in this i'm did you feel like you
know you hear the word brainwashed and i
you always think come on how can someone
get brainwashed well you know
working with i haven't really talked
about this but like working with allison
and seeing her grow up and uh
you know i never really hung out with
her maybe a couple cast dinners and
you know directed her and she was really
sweet and you know she
yeah she was always really nice needed
attention who doesn't i know i do
and you know there were certain things
um but you ask yourself
how does someone just
completely it's almost like you you're
leaving your skin
somewhere and you're i i can't explain
it because
knowing allison for those years and just
sitting around sitting but you know i
never you never imagined in a million
years that's why i think i neglected
sort of uh to read about it or really
it's like
this can't be there's got to be
something
but you probably saw her change
i did and and when you first met her
because
you know it is it's still hard for me to
believe i mean there was an incident at
my house um
years later um still i don't know if i
was on so i don't think i was on
smallville but
she and a friend of hers and this guy
said hey i'm gonna talk to you forever
we wanna stop by
and i hadn't seen her and they walked in
the house
and it was almost like i i just remember
i'm not being
uh i'm not blowing this out of
proportion i'm not exaggerating at all i
remember because my friend ethan was
here
and i remember we just kind of go and i
didn't by the way i didn't even know
about this
next team or anything at this point i
mean i remember on set once
she came and she was like hey you should
take this class it's really cool and
blah blah
and i remember i said to tom sounds like
a cult i don't know and we kind of
laughed but we never thought oh it's
like you know
i'm sure it's like people are looking
for things we never did it but i never
but but after that you know we never
really heard about it
it just she that was what she was doing
and i never really thought about it
so years later i don't know what year
this is i i have to go back and i could
probably figure it out
but i think it was after smallville she
you know she's in the vicinity she comes
over the house
and she walks in and she walked in
she was a different person she walked in
like she owned my house
like literally she owned my home
she walked in with her friends and they
walked into the kitchen i was like hey
she was like hey how are you and then
walked into my kitchen started bringing
out pots and pans and started cooking i
go
uh what are you guys doing my friend
ethan's like
it's like we're hungry we're hungry
we're we're gonna we're gonna i remember
that like it was yesterday
i got to talk to ethan because then
i said after a while i just felt
uncomfortable i was like well hey you
guys you know
uh like that's it come on you know let's
you know it's
and i kind of asked them like hey you
know you might want to leave soon and
that was gonna be nice
the guy turned almost violent he was
violent like he
wasn't he i can't remember who it what
his name i know because i didn't care i
just was like who the [ __ ] is this guy
very angry and like just i think he was
on something
he was like and he just started kind of
cursing at me and ethan i was like [ __ ]
you i'm like are you know what buddy i
don't know what this is about you just
come in you start cooking in my house
you guys don't even say that why don't
you guys just go well i'd actually like
you to get the [ __ ] out of my house
that's what i said and i remember i was
waiting for allison to sort of jump in
and say i'm so sorry no no he doesn't
mean this
there was nothing it was just like it
was almost like they were zombies that's
how i remember i'll never forget it
and i'm not saying that that the this
has anything to do with next thing i was
going to do it
but when they left i looked at ethan and
our hearts were racing and i'm like
oh my god i'm disgusted i i don't you
know and i remember i got a text maybe a
few days later
oh sorry about the other night or
something i don't it's bizarre
but i'm just telling you that i i don't
know where it came from i don't know
what happened
maybe it was a bad night but it was
years after i had seen her i hadn't seen
her for a long time
so i think what i'm saying is did you
when you first met her to the time
all this [ __ ] went down what was that
transformation like what was that sort
of relationship
i mean i'm going to backtrack for one
sec because you said something about
brainwashing
and it's important that people
you know either either you're of the
mind of like
we're all brainwashed it's just another
word is indoctrinated we're
indoctrinated by society by our parents
to believe certain things
you know commercials and doctrine in us
we it's hap
it's not a matter of whether we're
brainwashed or not just how brainwashed
are you
right that's one belief right right i
didn't understand how this worked until
i left
quick plug for a book that really helped
me understand it's called combating cult
mind control by stephen hassan and it
explains
how in a seminar you can be
indoctrinated
especially in three days that's why by
day three they had me their hooks were
in me
and it goes step by step and i'm not an
expert i can't
even begin to try to explain what he
explains in this book but if people want
to understand
better that happens but for somebody
like allison
and and keep in mind i was there for
some things i wasn't there for other
things
i can only i'm kind of hypothesizing
what happened with her
you know and i also don't want to like
bring any more
hurt on her and her family i want her to
be better i want her to wake up and i've
heard by the way that she has which is
great
yeah that's that's what i was sort of
hoping i was hoping that like because i
don't know anything other than i just
remember her as a sweet girl and i hope
that
i just kept hoping i was wrong or people
were wrong and i just don't know how it
happened so continue sorry you know what
what i remember is from that first
training and i had met her
casually through a group of friends um
you know at a bar
like at a party super outgoing great
dancer i remember thinking like her
style was really great great singer
great singer really friendly very um i
liked how like she was very touchy
you know lots of hugs um and i really
liked her a lot
and after that first training i think
because she was
um she wasn't working the next day she
she got on the plane
and went back to albany to meet keith
after two days
and i don't some people have said it was
like the
private jet i don't know i don't as a
rumor is a private jet or
either way she got on the plane went
back and met keith and that
video footage that you see in the vow of
them meeting at volleyball
like i've never seen that even though
that footage existed when i watched that
two weeks ago i was like
[ __ ] i mean people don't didn't normally
meet keith until you'd have to take a
minimum
16 day so the fact that they let
you know allison into that world and she
felt probably very special
to get special access to the vanguard
i think it's all things that um many of
us
that were you know were our actors like
wanting to be
feel important feel special get
attention um
i think she got all that and and uh that
was after two days yeah she had well it
was a three-day training in vancouver
and she flew back and and met him and
and i'm sure he's i don't know about you
but i got i mean i felt nauseous i felt
got chills when i saw that video like
how he was looking at her and what he
and what he said to her and
he was [ __ ] with her mind and like
bearing into her soul with his eyes like
you could just see the whole
history unfold from there um
but i didn't see that i didn't i didn't
go back i missed all that
there's so much i was like i wish i'd
like the behind the scenes that you're
seeing in the vow i'm like i wish i'd
known this was going on i would
there's no way i would have participated
like all that stuff was behind closed
doors
but wait a minute but mark knew all
about that though well
he he filmed all that right here yeah
mark was there filming
but the the sexual stuff was kept from
us
like he he knew that that keith was
mentoring women
um and i knew he mentored people but i
didn't know what mentor had meant
you know like that all that stuff came
out after we left
i was told he was celibate i mean it's
ridiculous to even think that
well didn't he have a wife at one point
who died of cancer who no
i thought pam was his assistant so it
may he made it like he was
he didn't have any women he didn't need
sex he didn't need anything
materialistic now towards the end of my
time there
after the indoctrination about that he
sort of implanted about polyamory
i thought is he with pam maybe he is huh
it's not in my business
but in my early years i was like keith
is a celibate monk
that's how he painted himself so seeing
that footage
i know it's i know i didn't know that
you didn't know that so going back and
looking at all that now now
rewinding the vowel on hbo now you watch
that thinking
wow sarah didn't know about it if she
would have known about that you probably
have been like i'm
on the [ __ ] out right absolutely yeah
i mean here's what i know now he
mentored women
to work through their issues by having a
sexual relationship with them
and that included taking this is even
before dos
these women had vowed to be with him for
the rest of their lives and not to be
with anyone else
and that was kept a secret and they were
told to keep it a secret because
we wouldn't understand people were too
um hit too many issues around sex and
they just wouldn't get it
who knew about this then at that point
besides nancy
nancy knew about it um lauren knew about
it
um i mean it seems like from doing the
math there's some
somewhere between 12 and 20 women that
he was with that he was
mentoring and sleeping with
mentoring through sex yeah and the way
it was
presented to women was i'm gonna help
you work your issues and your intimacy
issues
um and we're gonna be you know and i'll
be with you but i am with other women
and some of the women didn't even know
about the other women
like barbara boucher at first didn't
know about the other woman that she
freaked out and then you know had her
whole thing about it
so some people didn't know and some
people knew and that's one of the things
i was so pissed off about when i left
and why i was so vocal i was like you
know if you want to have a polyamorous
little farm up in albany
go for it but if you're saying you're
doing this other thing and you're not
going to put it on your website
it's a [ __ ] lie and here i am like
going out and vouching and
and by the way what you said the
beginning of our conversation you would
have signed up
if i'd met you in 2010 i totally would
have signed you
up you would have loved it you would
have loved the five day you would have
been all on board
and you would have gotten great tools
from it and then to find out
that i'm like i'm vouching i'm a
salesperson and like going out in the
world saying keith is the most noble
humanitarian blah blah blah blah
guy and he's doing this with all those
women it was like a
massive head [ __ ] for me yeah i can
imagine i mean you've
you've changed your whole life given
everything you had your whole life
is upside down everything to someone who
you really believe in
and innately is a you know
a good helpful person as to what you
know to what you
know at the time but it just feels like
i mean that's got to be the worst
feeling to find out
i mean your whole world i mean it's just
crashing down on you and like you were
wrong knowing that you're like
that that's the hardest part and i think
like
we'll talk about dos for a second doss
is
the wait wait before we oh yeah yeah
yeah
we joked about back and forth on email
about like how i take ativan on sunday
nights after the vow
one of the other reasons i went to esp
was for anxiety okay i haven't
i've had anxiety since probably my
parents split up different levels of it
i have trouble so do i so do i yes i
know right so
you probably dabbled and mostly i do cbd
oil
and stuff like that but anyway when this
happened
i had such a huge ptsd basically like
months and months of the worst anxiety
i've ever had in my life because my
whole world was suddenly
you know turned upside down and not only
that like to know that i was pushing
something peddling something that was
i thought was one thing not only wasn't
the opposite it was so bad
so bad that was this like you know and i
still have
panic attacks and ptsd reactions when
certain things happen or i see things on
the vow and i'm like oh my god
what is my life but yes das you wanted
to ask about dawson i mean by the way
does mark who
you know it's all his footage he had
been shooting us he was hired by keith
to just give sort of a you know back
story and
and sort of film everything uh the
history of this whole organization
and that if you look back you could look
at it now and say oh well that's like
look at that i want
it's you know look how self-indulgent i
wanted to be filmed i want you to film
me all the time
and um it's a surprise like sometimes by
filming some of that stuff and watching
the looks i'm like
because mark does seem like such a great
guy that mark wouldn't be like this is
[ __ ] creepy dude look how he's
looking at zones
i mean there's definitely some of that i
mean look hindsight is 20 20 and i'm
sure there's some things he overlooked
because he's like this is the most you
know because i remember he got emotional
he talked to keith he thought he was
just a genius he was like
one of the smartest people in the world
he was like this guy has a and
some insight that i'll never have and
enlightenment and all these things and
i'm
buying it and help me and wow this is
amazing that i'm just going to overlook
that creepy [ __ ] look he just gave
i'm sure there was a i'm sure i can't
speak for him but i'm sure he did i mean
we
there's a lot of red flags we all
overlooked because
we just couldn't handle like when you're
so invested at a certain point
like there are things that i saw that i
was like i remember visiting
um visiting somebody else's leave her
name out of it
hoping that she wakes up but i visited
somebody um who'd moved there and i was
like can we get together
and she was like i can't i need to be
accessible for i need to be ready for
keith and i was like
ready for what she's like we're doing
some projects and you know when you get
a hit that's people are sleeping
together
you just like get that like hold up oh
yeah okay right
yeah yeah and i had that and then i was
like
no he's like the teacher that's so
inappropriate and also she was
in her early 20s and he was like almost
50. so it's like i had the thought and
then i was like
it's impossible i also didn't find him
attractive so i was like she wouldn't do
that
right right he wouldn't do that because
it wasn't right
you know there's a certain code of
ethics as a therapist you don't sleep
with your clients
right but you were kind of overlooking
things that you might not have
overlooked because of just like the
situation you're in
right yeah yeah and and a belief you
know
that makes sense it makes sense i
underestimated their capacity to lie to
us
well not only that if like you know your
best friend in the world you know him
inside out he's the best and you're like
you know i
this guy would do anything i trust him
with anything and then you find out that
he just killed someone you're like no
there's no [ __ ] way dude that dude i
known him
he wouldn't kill someone i know well do
you remember when he had that knife and
he was like you know i want to [ __ ]
ah but he was kidding was he kidding
holy [ __ ] maybe i wasn't kidding
look dos you didn't when did you know
about dos how many years in and when did
you the first time you heard about dog
oh just a few months before i left
and that was to bonnie
we're getting into the the very end here
yeah yeah so i
i found out in january and i left in
june so
it was the really the beginning of the
end for my me and my time there
oh honey bunny can the baby be in the
podcast is that going to be distracting
okay right there
yeah yes yes sorry yes i got so caught
up in it but yes i want to just get it
there's so honestly like there's so much
to unpack with this
right and by the way one thing i one
moment i did want to mention
when you asked about my arc with alison
and what did i notice
we got married in 2010 and i invited
allison to the wedding
and um i remember her saying i have got
a check with keith
very casually let me check let's go ask
keith and i was like
are you seven is he your daddy i don't
understand
like i didn't and i even said that like
why didn't you have to check with keith
and she's like well i've been i make
really impulsive decisions and i told
keith i would check with him before i
leave town
and that that was a red flag for sure i
just didn't
couldn't make sense of that like okay so
keith's mentoring her
she can't you know just wants to make
less impulsive decisions so there were
things like that over
over time that i clocked but she just
got more and more committed she was more
committed than i was i mean she was
she was living there she she gave up her
home in in um
vancouver she's living where she was
living did she have her own place
she had her own place in albany your own
place but keith also lived there
in albany oh no five minutes five
minutes oh the monkey
oh i know i'm sorry
he's like really he's really mad at me
isn't it mad
ace aces 18 months and he's
he likes to cuddle after his nap anyway
daddy got him he's okay
all right look so da stands for uh
dominus
obsequious sororium yeah that's what
that is
and so this is something you found out
and and
again i mean how do you get caught up in
this how does this happen
what's the step that this just it's so
complicated and
partly because i hate talking about it
and also because the baby's out
look right you could look you can watch
the vow watch the vowel or read the book
like there's so many steps that happen
of how i got hooked into it and how they
manipulate particularly lauren how she
manipulated me
and leveraged her trust with me to
commit to something that i never would
have committed to but ultimately it's
the
thing that everyone's heard about in the
news the branding right it's the
branding it's the branding that sort of
yeah and i just like for my own self
wellness i have to totally not talk
about that because it's just too
triggering but ultimately it's what woke
me up
not in the moment but weeks later when i
figured out that the symbol was not what
they told me it was actually the
initials of
we still don't know for sure if it was
alice and mac on purpose but am
and kr for keith renery i mean that
set me off like you know the thing i was
talking about earlier where i was pissed
off about the straight path like
that was one thing when i figured that
out at the same time mark and i were
finally having
you know conversations about what was
going on why he was leaving and he knew
certain things at this point he knew
about the sex and i knew about the
branding and we talked
and shared what we both knew it's it's
what
you know it's what woke us up we're like
you know we are in a cult
we're gonna call we actually are in a
culture right i guess you know when you
hear about people sort of like uh
you know the manipulation of like hey
you're gonna have to give
uh something in return collateral you're
gonna have to
take a nude picture of yourself you're
gonna have to do this in order to
because and i guess in your mind you're
thinking well if this is such a secret
no one's gonna know about it i'm never
gonna tell anybody they have to do
something to trust so you kind of buy
into that whole thing i guess
yeah absolutely i mean also the person
inviting me was somebody i would have
you know she was our my son's our first
son's godmother she was my
maid of honor okay we're done okay he's
gonna join us
join us join us look how cute you are
look how cute you are you're a good boy
you're a handsome little fella aren't
you
that's right so let me just ask you i
mean
i mean when you got home in nippy and he
finds about this stuff you see it in the
documentary which you guys could watch
but
it probably was hell for a bit right it
was hell but
he you know he got it it was there was
never a like
you know how could you have done this
you know
he you have to understand that all so
many years in esp we were
there was so much bad press and we
always thought it's a smear campaign
it's a smear campaign keith is good
nobody understands
all of a sudden we understand that we
were wrong
and you know if you really want to know
who keith is you just google him and all
that time we thought those things were
lies and we're like okay
we're out and it was kind of a relief
you know it was like all these things
that we were struggling with with the
company and trying to make it work and
it was like
you know do you think sashes and
vanguard is ever going to fly like in a
training really like
we were trying to change those things
because really you're right the tools on
the outside and part of the curriculum
was great
but a lot of that stuff was just such
[ __ ] and it was so hard to make it
fly
and all of a sudden it was like okay we
can just move on now and get back to our
lives i mean but it's gotta be the
hardest thing to all of a sudden say
this is what this is i gotta go tell my
parents what this is uh
nippy's gotta tell his parents your
friends and like hey
yeah you know sometimes it's like that
sort of that you know admitting that you
were wrong but of course you hindsight
is 20 you can't you can't know you're
wrong you fee you know you're thinking
that this is going to help you
and it's got so many you know good
things about it
and then it turns out to be like we
talked about in the beginning of horror
movie
and then you're like how do we get out a
lot of time in fact i'm still
running into people going i'm sorry and
you were right
um but yeah the first conversations with
my family were pretty heartbreaking but
they were so
so accepting and not no no that's too
loud
i'm not getting nippy on here wasn't it
why don't you take over for a few
minutes i'll talk to nippy
no no aid is too loud but come join us
why don't you sit here for a minute
yeah yeah bring your coffee over here
it's a family affair you know yeah
no it was really it was i mean like i
said i'm still having those
conversations and i'm still
he's coming um apologizing and making
amends
um but in some ways it was a
relief to go you know oh my god i was
i was wrong and but all these things now
made sense that i had never been able to
wrap my head around
but the people who still remain loyal i
mean they're
they've they've never been able to take
a bite out of that [ __ ] sandwich for
lack of a better word
you know they're they're still walking
around going oh my gosh
are you shaving what are you doing
what's going on there oh he's doing two
shots
two shots yeah we have an espresso oh i
think that sounds like alcohol like you
taking two shots from the day
nip you quick shots at tequila ask me
one more question will i stop her
it's all for nippy yeah i mean look i
i'd have to say
if if you were one-on-one with keith
renery right now
in a room what would you say to him hmm
well he'll come over here babe here you
go hey nippy how you doing bud
good to see you man um my my answer to
that
probably would have changed over the
past couple years i think you know when
i was still really angry
three years ago i would have said you
know torn him a new one and
said you know you messed with the wrong
person what are you thinking and how
dare you
but uh i don't know i'm kind of like in
the
forgiveness and not in the sense of like
he still needs to go to jail but like
just for my own sanity
not to hold that anymore right um to let
that go and just be like you know i hope
he's got a dark soul i mean he did some
bad things to people and i just
you know i hope he can
i don't know nippy what about you i'd
like to know nippy i i have a feeling he
might have a different interpretation
what would you say to keith renery well
they have to put you in
will they have to restrain you i think
there's much i could say to him that
would uh
change him um or anything but i'm dying
to find out if he's a real judo champion
a real judo champion like you know he
says he's a
judo champion and that was his is on his
resume i don't want to kick the tires on
that how long do i have with him i
haven't
right i mean if you had like f 10
minutes to go let's see how strong you
are
yeah that's right
i mean look you guys for a lot would you
say a lot of this before all this stuff
went to hell and you found out the
horrors of it all did you say
you were pretty happy you were in it to
win it you kind of felt like this was
helping humanity and this is a good
thing
for the most part yeah that was the
delusion that was the lie i mean that's
what
you know that the whole thing in getting
out was just reconciling that's what we
were never doing
i mean we were helping people like that
there was tangible evidence we were
doing that
but the whole thing that we were going
to somehow get involved and
i'll let you take other hierarchies
other structures and help them anything
that got
close to that um always had some
what seemed like arbitrary excuse for
not happening
for example there were many people that
tried to get it into certain
universities harvard business school
tuck dartmouth and there was always
something that happened
that prevented other people's
connections
to really getting these good ideas which
i've kind of found are mostly
regurgitated and just honed and you can
get them anywhere
i mean um i think the cool part about it
was just people coming together and
helping each other was
it's always positive you don't have to
make it your life and anything that was
going to translate to something bigger
it was just never going to happen
because i think
he knew on some level if you get someone
in here with
standards and practices that have been
tried and tested
his modality would be exposed for
stolen fraudulent and his real intent
would be exposed so
he knew that and he knew that um in
order to get
to maintain his lie he had to prevent
people from coming in and doing that
right sarah i hear that padding very
loudly but that you have to do it yeah
you have to pat the kid it's fine just
paddling
more gently for god's sakes i'm just
kidding
but nippy i mean you're a good-looking
guy you know you're a quarterback ivy
league school you're a smart guy i've
heard you on the value you're very
articulate
i mean so some people would say and it's
a good example because it's like
well this guy got into it why would he
get into it if he can get into it
certainly a more feeble-minded person
can get into it somebody who's more
vulnerable what was it that you
llama got kind i mean take all that off
of me the dalai lama got conned and he
was supporting and he wrote a forward
for the guy's book
so i think ultimately what happened is
the people around him
um you look have you read that book um
sapiens i haven't read it real quick he
just basically talks about
one of the things that made us go from
hunter and gatherers to social beings is
that we had a common myth
that we all believed in and it goes to
banking systems governments and all that
stuff united states of america the myth
of america is you come here and you
actualize your dreams and all that there
was a myth everyone was enrolled into
and that keith was um doing good things
and wasn't
you know this idea i mean i'm watching
the vow now and i'm seeing
how he's treating people he was rude to
people
i mean one of the things that's so
shocking to me is how disgusting a human
being he was to other people
i never saw that i never saw him behave
that way so the myth was cultivated
pretty well
if you weren't in his direct orbit and
sarah and i were peripheral
and when we came to came to albany took
a training or
or did whatever you know went to an
event or something like that
the myth seemed intact right and as long
as the myth seemed intact
um it seemed like we were doing
something good
so when we would go out and
and hear these things about keith or
whatever come back and ask people
that we were lied to we were flat out
lied to people by that we trusted that
were in our lives for ten years and
didn't
didn't think they were uh they would do
that we underestimated that you know the
one thing that was baffling to me is
sort of like
and again i'm not there but like you
know those nine women on the board
it's nine women and keith right and
those nine women
left and you'd think that right when you
hear that
nine women left the whole thing that you
think everybody was like i'm getting the
[ __ ] out of here
something's [ __ ] how did he manipulate
that
so some of the nine women it was really
about three
and they were higher yeah they're high
rank um and i think those were the three
that he had to discredit because
they were going to take some people with
him so it looked like those three took
their friends with him
but the three that really got
discredited and really barbara shea and
susan doanes yeah the two people that
were in the last episode
um they had been working on making them
crazy to the organization for quite some
time because i think keith will keith
was sleeping with one of them so he knew
how to do that
right and what made our exit different
from theirs is ours was abrupt
we didn't try to all right we didn't try
and we didn't have a try i wasn't going
to have an intellectual debate about the
merits of branding someone's
body to teach them growth and character
that wasn't something i was even
remotely interested it was there wasn't
there wasn't a pause in that i was out
right and i told sarah she had come back
with as much as a
scrape on her arm i would have been in
there with the same reaction like that's
not what we're doing here
um so to answer your question about them
they had been made crazy
to the organization and quite literally
when you do that to someone what was
done to barbouche which none of us had
any idea
she kind of did go a little bit crazy
she had all her wealth taken
she challenged him and was made crazy
was gaslit and all those things so
we didn't trust her yeah the emergent
property of someone who's been through
that kind of trauma they look a little
crazy
so when we went to and i'm not i'm not
saying barbara she's crazy at all i'm
saying that she had been through the
wringer and you were experiencing
someone who had been through the wringer
and had some trauma going
unbeknownst to us and we were going to
nancy
lauren and the people around her and
they were saying that she came in trying
to take over there
you know so you know i think you know
if we're guilty if i'm guilty of
something is i didn't go investigate
that responsibly enough but i also
didn't think
to investigate it right that much did
you guys talk to allison after the
branding
did you ever ask her hey is this your
signature your
your letters your initials they were
shunning us at that point yeah i mean
we knew we were the bad guys but listen
my whole thing is
when this happened um
i didn't really have a strong impulse to
tell my side of the story
i mean except to tell my side of the
story i knew time would tell it
and i knew if there was ever any sort of
investigation or whatever goes on and
the cards are on the table
they were going to be way closer to who
we were saying they were than vice versa
and that they were clearly in the wrong
in the wrong um uh as for alison i
didn't
i don't remember if i had any
communication whether i sent some texts
that were like wtf
like what did you do to my wife sort of
thing on here and then
i sent some to some other people and
then i kind of felt
you know i knew the wheels of their
litigation was they go into motion i
think it's in the vow too
i think pretty much when the new york
times article came
out i knew that they were going to be on
the heels and this is this is my
impression of what goes on behind the
scenes i don't really know i'm not close
to it and we got
a little bit of a crash course in how
litigation fbi works and all that stuff
but i actually
did simple google searches you know and
i found out once he got investigated
once they open up an fbi
investigation gets opened up you can go
to the website
and there's a [ __ ] flow chart and it
basically goes if these things hit these
things like
you know corrupt if you're going to get
evidence and your evidence is
corroborated
there's a point where like if it gets to
a certain point 80
of the time you're screwed if the fbi is
going to take their time
so you knew it was coming to an end yeah
time to go
and the fact that they don't know if the
fbi is knocking on your door
you know what i mean most people right i
watch basic
cop shows yeah yeah yeah yeah
well no if the fbi is knocking on your
door
something's up and they double down
this is gonna be you know for for me it
was
vindication my i got my wife and kid as
out of there as quickly as possible
when the new york times did that and
then they opened i felt like okay i
think we're safe
like i think i say in the vowels like
there's not much they can do to us
like they're they're done and like it's
not in our hands anymore right
so they can't attack our character in
our process anymore they now have to
attack
the media's process and the loyalists
that are still there are now attacking
the government's process by demanding an
affidavit
so it's never refute the points
of convicted felon on seven counts in a
jury of his peers
um in under four hours by the best
domestic police task force in human
history
right i mean maybe the romans had one
back in the day that was pretty good but
we don't know about that
right um and the onus is on you now and
you can go
fix the fbi's process and the
government's process in a legal press
you know it's just
right they're never refuting content i
think keith's going to get life
i think so and i mean if brockman got 81
months and he's trying to have his trial
outside of the court when he said
nothing in court and he's doing
all this stuff to get his loyalists to
go do stuff
i think he's insulting the court he's
insulting the judge and the judge sent a
message to claire bronfman why wouldn't
he send it to him
and anyone else who has those kinds of
ideas and who else
who else do you think is gonna go to
prison um well i know that lauren and
nancy are gonna go to prison i don't
know that they're gonna go for as long i
think they're controlling i think
they're still reconciling from what i
understand what they've done and i think
let's listen it's hard like
when reconciling your delusion eating
your humble pie
is a hard thing um you know it and
and i don't know what they've done i
don't have any intel
as to we can't talk about them um what
how they've done it i think they're
contrite
lauren's testimony put the nail in the
coffin for keith in a lot of ways
um i understand and if they truly are
contrite the judge
sees that i think he's going to give
them the minimum
and in hopes that they do well
i'm not a point where i'm angry at
anyone um anymore
um but the delineation i have is
if you knew me and you knew that i knew
what you knew about keith
and you kept that from me that means you
lied to keep me
loyal to something that wasn't true and
that that's my life you [ __ ] with my
life and you knew you did and you knew
that what i stand for isn't what he
stands for and i wouldn't have been on
board with
it just makes me really uncomfortable
just that feeling that that's how you
guys
were operating and you know i i happen
to know that lauren had been had a
sexual relationship
with him since 2001 that was the year i
did my first training
you know and then in 2003 i left because
i didn't think vanguard sashes and
bowing was going to catch on
um i should listen to that
and uh so that to me is where like
i can forgive you and hope for the best
but we're not
we're not gonna have coffee and talk
about it hey this this you know i'm only
gonna ask one of these questions from my
uh
my patrons i just felt like this one
question this could go for both of you
when you go about your is from aisha
when you go about your everyday life do
you still hear the voices of your coach
lauren or keith telling how to you know
how to act or how to be
uh how do you combat them to or combat i
said combat you can say combat can't you
uh to maintain your peace of mind as a
victim of abuse
you know she says i have moments like
that that still trigger me
i don't i don't know the questions
necessarily
that applicable uh i guess their
teachings and what they taught you do
you still are there some that are sort
of
embedded in you i i think what i hear
them asking is
how do you how do you discern the good
from the bad and
and yeah um look
the goods you can get anywhere else
i think a lot of the stuff is repackaged
in a lot of places
um the thing that the immediate road i
went down
when this was over was figuring out the
con
and i think what happens is when you're
exploring your own belief system
they can suggest things to you and
depending on
i think it's case by case depending on
how susceptible you are to suggestion
is how indoctrinated you become um
there's a book about it
um called take back your life
and i think the woman yanni lalich goes
into eight specific things that people
fall for
the one that resonated the most with me
was called moral injury
uh meaning that there were some
principles you thought you were
holding um and you found out that the
principles
were the hook to get you loyal to
something so to put it in maybe
um context for some people i think she
puts this in context in her book
um think of a soldier who's going over
thinking he's fighting for peace and the
next thing you know he's pulling women
and children out of a hut and he's
you know in a compromising situation
where
he's doing something in war that isn't
congruent with peace
that that i think is a lot of things
that soldiers reconcile
all the time yeah they signed up for
something
it's not that thing and they recognize
the reason they got signed up they got
con
and and the hard part for me was like
okay i can make a mistake
i can pivot on the mistake but to think
that i
led people down that path and i rose
through a hierarchy
brought in over 150 people you know to
something and i know how to go i had to
go face them
and also destroy something i'd worked
really really hard to build is
also difficult yeah well dude i really
appreciate you uh i know you weren't
intending to get on here but i love that
you did because i really like
like listening you know on the on the
documentary and
you're just such a supportive husband
and look look after sarah does get
branded i
you know i mean as a husband you're
probably like you could hear it you're
you're not happy about it but you're
more unhappy with these
these people i was primal i had all the
oh yeah
you know and i just decided
look i'm not going to handle my problems
with violence i think everyone loses
but it was a close second
were you honestly thinking about i gotta
go there now and i gotta handle this got
a moment when we were
um we were planning kind of our escape
we had about four or five days to do it
and i knew that there was volleyball
going on i never i
went to volleyball once a year like i
just i just wasn't my thing and
you know i i we didn't live near there i
had to drive 30 minutes to go there
um partly because i didn't want people
checking in on me and i like to watch
football on sunday smoke a dub and drink
a beer and i didn't want someone coming
by and bother me right
right we weren't really supposed to do
that but you thought
at that moment you were gonna stop by
the volleyball court didn't you oh
well i get off the phone with mark and
i'm like
[ __ ] this and i and i you know
you know how when the lights are on in
your apartment and it's dark outside and
i look over and catch myself
but it's okay in my reflection in the
mirror and i look and i'm like
there was the moment where i felt
everything come up if you commit to this
this could be bad news bad and i caught
myself
and ultimately you know i don't think
i'm that kind of person
to to handle my problems that way i
think everyone loses and
another thing stopping me too is i was
probably gonna have to hit a couple
people on the way out
[Music]
probably trying to stop him right well
it's like i was like i was like i could
i'm gonna have to hit him
him ah right yeah i was after one guy
and i went after
you know three or four well i'm glad you
didn't do that i had my escape plan i
had it all planned
yeah i mean did you ever like talk to
sarah obviously she doesn't talk about
probably in the in the book it's not
like it's a secret because she's
you guys are pretty much open books but
like i can't i'm like i'm a puss i can't
even imagine being brandon that has to
be the worst pain
ever right that's a question for sarah i
haven't been branded
worst pain ever worst pain ever with the
brain yeah i mean she says so
it's it was a cute um
it's up there with childbirth you know
it's very very
it's the most sensitive area of your
body and there's no anesthetic and how
long does that last like
when they put something on you like that
is it like like five seconds
uh well they drew each line with the
cauterizing iron which is basically
slicing open
your flesh so like
sorry baby yeah
um per line and then she stopped and
like read something
some sort of scripture that i don't
remember what it was because it was
totally disassociated
out of my body that's just it's just
incredible i mean
yeah my theory is that it was him trying
to do it what i've learned about since
sorry about the noise sorry trauma
bonding so like
some of the women that remain are the
women that ran it together and they feel
really close because they got through
this
traumatic situation together so um
i think that's what he was trying to do
like to really help people stay loyal
forever is to have that experience that
they could
well yeah listen uh nippy sarah i mean i
got to say this with you i'm i'm
so appreciative for you guys being so
forthcoming and so open and like
because this happens a lot of places and
it's unfortunate that it could have been
one of those things that was just good
like you guys innately thought and it
could have been something great
and there had to be this dark twist and
this horror aspect of it all and i'm
just you know i'm truly sorry but i'm
also truly grateful that you opened up
and you could educate people on your
book scarred
that just came out sarah is like talk
about
she even gets deeper trust me and uh
nippy
just for you guys to open up about it
it's gonna help people out there because
a lot of people are vulnerable and they
suffer from anxiety and depression all
these things
and they look for a place to go and some
kind of acceptance and that's not the
only reason they go but
you know it's a shame that this all
happened and i'm just glad that you're
because some people could just say i
don't want to be involved i want to be
i'm sure you fought that and thought i
don't want to be a part of this
and to just tell the world your secret
it probably gets that
you know what do you call that you know
the that that monster off your back you
know that
gorilla off your back that feeling of
like you know you got it there's got to
be some peace that comes with that
is definitely what we've needed to do to
turn this negative
into oh honey come here buddy come here
come here buddy
come here beep beep yes it's a beep beep
turning the negative into a positive
um and since we haven't been our mantra
yeah like
okay thank you michael thank you thanks
nippy thanks so much man nice meeting
you just
just to comment on that there's been a
lot of people since being public
reaching out saying i'm in this group
it sounds just like what you're
describing in the vow how do i get out
how do i expose it
or i know somebody in a group like this
how do i get out how do i expose it
these things exist that a lot of them
exist more than people know
yeah and a lot of people are bound to
these things and don't know how to get
out and
hopefully this bye-bye i'll see you
later okay see the park
um yeah it's just what we got to do now
it's like you know even even the playing
field yeah
well i command you i do and it's like
you know it was hard it was just like i
always people always ask me about
allison i was just like i just always
knew her as this great girl i didn't
really know her other than she was just
a really terrific girl and a great
actress and i just liked working with
her and it was so sad and
you know i just i couldn't believe it
and you know i really
i believe that you know something
happened where she just
wasn't herself you know yeah actually
like
since that's our common friend um
among other few others but you know it
makes me really sad what he did to her
and i i really hope that she has woken
up and i hope that
she's somebody i would see again and
have coffee and talk about
the time where we were in that call yeah
i would and all these women that you
know
suffered and all these people that
suffered it's just it's tragic and i'm
not saying
you know you can't say oh poor allison
you have to say poor everybody because
there was no winner in this
everybody around keith to a degree even
though they did illegal things our
victims yeah
him nobody signed up for this none of us
signed up for what they ended up doing
and
including allison and i i just wish her
all the best and her family all the best
so it's you know it's a tragic awful
thing and i appreciate you
taking time to shine light on it yeah
thank you by the way my podcast is
usually an hour an hour into 20 and i
just was so into this that i'm sorry i
went over i know it's about an hour and
40 minutes and i'm like good lord i'm
but i was so into it so thank you so
much for opening up and
all my love and keep in touch and good
luck with the family and everything
awesome and the book scarred guard okay
escaping nexium the cult that found my
life but i'm out i'm out didn't buy my
life here i am
exactly all right lady definitely keep
in touch you got it good luck with your
anxiety
yeah i'm working on it i'm working on it
we can share it we can share secrets
we can't know what works and it doesn't
work yeah you have daughters don't show
any calls
i'm not going to join a cult i you know
it's funny that
so many years ago i remember going
sounds like a cult kid just kidding like
i'm sure it's not
and then going i mean because whoever
goes into a co
no one gets into a cult because it's
they think it's a cult they get into it
because they think it's just great
and that's how it all begins that's how
it works all right all my love go take
care of that little crying baby
okay well thank you
well if that wasn't intense ryan i don't
know what was
that was a rough one yeah sometimes i
don't i don't even know what to ask
anymore like i asked
this branding hurt but ultimately that's
what i just because i kept thinking oh
my gosh i mean i could never
and you could tell sarah didn't want to
get into it because
it's a very emotional thing and it's a
personal thing and you probably read her
book
and i'm sure she'll get into it but it
is tragic man it's tragic because you
i think we all look for something or
someone something to have faith in
and when that lets us down it's just
it's devastating it's like oh this is
good for me
you know this uh i learned meditation
and this is great and this is helping me
and then
uh next thing you know you find out your
instructor's a psychopath or something
i think we just like look for answers
and um
you know could you could this have
happened to you
honestly honestly i don't i couldn't say
um i mean i've been lucky enough to
surround myself with
decent people who aren't uh crazy
well i would like to thank you know what
i would like to think i wouldn't but you
know who the [ __ ] knows
yeah i like to think that there's a
possibility that i would have in the
beginning if i was like you know i'm
kind of lost and i did
i felt lost i still feel lost at times i
mean i knew then
not to not to do it
but i who's to say that if someone that
i really respected
and kind of like not idolized but
somebody that i really
for instance my friend tom or my friend
ethan who are great guys
smart if they got into something like
that
and i was like really like dude
i'm sure they could probably talk me
into it because i just trust them
i think they're great guys and they have
good hearts and then you're
into it and then you're in five sessions
ten sessions and then you're starting to
reprogram your brain and you don't know
you're being mind
[ __ ] and you're being programmed to
not
trust your gut that was right scariest
part that's the scariest part could you
imagine
oh just [ __ ] man it is ah anyway
uh thank you to everybody who's
listening remember to subscribe and
email all your friends and do whatever
you can to keep the podcast rocking
thanks to westwood one thanks to ryan
here who edits the episodes
this guy right here to bryce who busts
his ass inside out and does everything
um to westwood one to
uh all my patrons uh we just had ins
uh uh a live ins instagram we haven't
done that in a while and it was fun and
thanks for the new members of patron
patreon to join and i'm going to name
them off now
the the the top tiers and a lot of good
stuff coming your way
and remember the inside of you online
store
wine glasses shirts hats uh sweatshirts
uh [ __ ] mugs autograph mugs if you want
em
all right here we go this is the patron
thanks for listening again by the way if
you wanna listen to this you can fast
forward but
don't if you really wanna hear your name
nancy d
mary b leah s trisha sarah v little lisa
you kiko
yukiko jill e brian h lauren g nico p
angelina g robin asks jerry w emily k
bobby robert i jason w stephen j kristen
k
amelia o allison l jess j lucas m
raj c emily s cjp
samantha m hamza jennifer n jackie p
stacy l carly h jennifer s you know
we're going to play a little game ryan
after i'm done with this i'm not going
to say the game yet i'm going to tell
you after right after
fun janelle b carrie b tabitha 272 not
to be confused with
top of the 273 kimberly e crystal h mike
e marissa
n that's correct namirello ramira
beth b santiago m sarah f chad w leanne
p correct roshan of course
rey a maya p
oh uh f nope j close maddie s tiffany i
kendrick f
ashley e margie m thomas t math w
belinda and benjamin r lisa j
kevin v robert s james r chris h snow
r sean v anusha w
ashbjorn and aj bjorn i believe h
age dave h sheila g and another new
member
jacob h all right now can you
name ten of these patrons i just said
um all right there's maya p
uh lisa j correct kendrick f
osborne hamza hamzabi
uh bob s is that one uh
yeah there's bob b bobby well you don't
get
bobby i don't get bobby then
um should i give you a hint uh
tabitha 272 yes
uh you kiko yes uh
oh my god
oh no oh ration rachen
yes um oh raj raj
and uh kevin v no
no kevin v is correct kevin v is correct
look at that
that's a fun game isn't it uh you guys i
can't i can't uh
say thank you enough to you guys out
there um i say it all the time and um
i just love doing this and i hope you
stay with me as long as i'm doing it
i can do it without you thanks to all
the patrons thanks to all the listeners
please subscribe please tell everybody
you emailing and making people uh
subscribe and listen
truly helps keep doing it uh
um keep fighting the good fight man just
keep
hanging in there man because we're gonna
get we're i feel like there's a light
i do i feel like there's a light we got
the election coming on and and by the
way i will say one thing and this isn't
directed at anybody
i love all of you but i will say if i
ever
i don't get political but if i ever say
things like i wear a mask or i do this
these are things that aren't political
these are things i just say
i i whatever you believe
is your belief your beliefs i don't
i'm not going to judge you don't judge
me if i say something that you think
well
you mean you hope i don't really talk
politics i just don't do it
but if i see something that i just feel
like is ridiculous i i
acknowledge it and if you don't agree
with it well we move on
we just move on so um
i'll just say that uh thank you all for
allowing me to be inside of you today
and um can't wait to talk to you again
and uh i do
sometimes in fact i just message a lot
of people on the patreon
if you haven't joined patreon check it
out patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you or inside
and uh it's a whole family and uh
there's a lot of great things that you
you get
merch and zooms and just a bunch of [ __ ]
just check it out all right much love
thanks ryan wanna say goodbye bye